should be about a probability yeah all
right you got to do a lot of reading
here
and interpretation what Bibles chosen at
random from a bag of marbles if the
probability of the bomb be read is 1
which state is true now one of the ways
it's easiest to help you work out which
of the cadance's it is is thinking about
1 think about as a percentage right
we're good at doing percentages how like
to vote 11.00 how do I convert that into
a percentage how do you convert any
number to a percentage you multiply by a
hundred don't you that gives you 100
percent you guys know what a hundred
percent means it's definitely gonna
happen right so if you are definitely
gonna get a red bubble that means all of
them have to be red because if one of
the wallet red then the chance would not
be a hundred percent which of these
events has the highest probability
probably the easiest way to go through
is think about all of them and work them
out as fractions think about which is
the biggest fraction a head on a coin
how many options are there on a coin
there are two heads of tails
so the head is one out of two we're all
your two on an old die how many options
are there how many faces are there there
are six so this is a six choosing Monday
at random there are seven days
choosing a from the vows that's one out
of five vowels so you can see this
number has the smallest denominator
which means it's the biggest one but I'm
okay Sofia toss a fair coin n times
three heads seven tails what's the
probability that the next toss would be
a head okay this is a bit of a steeper
question it's a it's a trick question
right they added all this information
ten times three heads seven tails but
they're crucial that you really need to
realize is it's a fair coin it's fair
that means that it's equally likely to
get a head or a tails every single time
it's kind of the own if you've heard of
a gambler's fallacy you know if
someone's gambled they gave money
they've lost many many times I can't on
a game they might think oh I'm more
likely to win for the next one it's not
true
the odds are still the same
okay yeah you can only do the one it's
unfortunately yeah it's and it's
designed to be tricky
it's designed to see if you really
understand how does probability work
right it's all about well what's the
likelihood at any given time and it's a
fair coin so that's why it's always
50/50 let's go to the next one choose
the correct phrase to complete the
following sentence I think most of you
went pretty well on this 4/5 it's more
than half right
so it's not this it's not certain that
it be 100% like we've looked at before
it's one of these which one is it
questions - well since it's more than
1/2 right it's not unlikely happen it's
likely to happen so that's how you get B
all right just the one answer it sound
like Jimmy Kevin play a game using a
spinner player wins where the spitter
stops on his color Jim always chooses
Creed Kevin always chooses wise which
spinner should tempt you so he has the
greatest chance of beating Jim
Kevin beats Jim so that means we want
green to beat white okay does that make
sense
wait did I do it the wrong way around
all the way around all the way around
sorry white beats green okay so
therefore what we want is for in
relation to each other we don't want to
be biggest right now have a look look at
the look at where the spinner is right
does that matter it does matter does it
it's actually again just like this
previous question it's just a trick it
doesn't matter what the previous turn
was what does matter is what the
proportions are and how they relate to
each other okay so for example here what
is the chance of white winning it's
broken up through the quarters isn't it
so it's it's 2 out of 4 2 quarters good
so white has a chance of 1/2 here right
two quarters what's the chance agree
with you well there's one quarter so
it's that's a quota so you can see
clearly White has a better chance of
beating green but we want the greatest
chance right so you have to look at the
rest of them you have a look at this one
for instance okay let's have a look
white white white that's three how many
are there in total six so it's three out
of six it's still a half for what isn't
it
what's the chance for green what's 1/2 2
out of 6 that's 1/3 so comparing just a
B and thinking about greed does green
have a better chance here or here and
the answer is is over here because the
fraction is bigger for green okay so
this is cheeky got to compare them I can
keep going through how look at this one
green and white equal chance right 1/3
1/3 and this last one how many sections
are there is 5 so that means you have
2/5 is that right did I calibrate ok so
when you have a look at those that's why
the greatest chance of beating Jim it
does look like these two are equal right
this one's twice as likely this one's
twice as likely but is a better option
why there's more space climate that's
true but there's much space covered for
both of them they like this is this is
bigger and this is bigger right 1/2 is
bigger than 2/5
but 1/4 is bigger than 1/5 as well so
why is this one better than this yeah
okay we're getting onto sample space it
does have to do this ever we're gonna
say something else
say I got a right but a good across
inanity yeah that's you not paying
attention you know is my initial so I
fixed it so okay all right now I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why this one is a
better option than this one you want it
to have a um you want Y to have a better
chance of beating green okay now what's
the chance that he beats green well in
this case it's 1/2 minus 1/4 okay that's
the difference between them now we can
do fractions that's 1/4 okay so this is
kind of you could think of this as his
advantage whose advantage the quarter
here now here what's the advantage well
it's two fifths minus one-fifth
well that's 1/5 now which of these is
bigger the answer is 1/4 that advantage
is bigger than this advantage okay so
even though you could say you're twice
as likely to win on white here they
agree and you're twice as likely to win
here on white big green but the
advantage between them
the gap is bigger okay so if you like
think about in these terms right maybe
you're watching a on a game of soccer
okay game of soccer right and what
you've got is one game where one team is
beating other one to one to one
okay so they've got twice the score of
the other team it more likely to win at
that point now if you watch another game
and the score is 20 to 10 now that
team's ten goals ahead even though the
score is twice as large right the gap is
ten ten goals right so therefore that's
why a is a better option
does that make sense very tricky
question all right let's keep going
together this is love a standard
six-sided dice die is nothing from 1 to
6 months they're probably rolling even
number you just got to know if the even
numbers are 2 4 8 6 there are 3 of them
right so 3 favorable outcomes over 6
tonal that's why I inter heart okay they
didn't ask you to simplify so that's why
either of them would be okay a bag
contain 7 blue to yellow and 1 green
marble one selected at random what's the
probability of not selecting a blue
marble now you could count up the
yellows and the greens but it's easier
just to say the probability of gave the
blue
is seven so which will seven are ten
sorry I should say so the probability of
not getting the blue is the rest of the
probability what this is called is a
complement if you remember we talked
about this right there opposite events
okay so this is a simpler way to work it
out even though if you did yellow which
is two out of ten and greed which is one
out of ten you'd still get the right in
itself either those methods were fun at
the page listed below are all the
possible outcomes for a family with
three children in terms of the gender of
the children okay those are all the
outcomes there one two three four five
six seven eight
outcomes what's the probably but in a
three child family there will be at
least one girl so you just have to look
at think which one of these how many of
these have at least one girl the answer
is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 of them have at least
one girl ok so that's where that 7 comes
from that you figure out how many total
options there are I already count them
up there are 8 so that's what 7 over 8
and you can't simplify any more next one
a coin is tossed then a standard dice is
rolled the possible outcomes are so you
got your heads your tails and then
you've got the number that comes with a
dime don't see queue up what's the
probability of obtaining tails will you
look at all the ones with your tails
right you could say it's 6 out of 12 but
you can just as easy to say look at this
half of them are here and the other half
are here so that's why the problem tells
just uh-huh
what's the probability of taking a tail
and a number less than 5 so because
they've got all of your outcomes here
your possible things that can happen you
just count up the right ones on tails
so I barely thinking about these bottom
ones then you want a number less than 5
1 2 3 4 so that's where the 4 comes from
for favorable outcomes there are 12
total added so you go 4 out of 12 and
that's 1 over 3 if you chose to simplify
who deck cards so for suits spades
hearts and diamonds and clubs what's the
problem that I selected diamonds okay
now don't these are simplified because
you have four suits it's evenly
distributed so you might not have
recognized that 52 divided by four
because there are four suits that's
going to be 13 so that's where that 13
comes from there are 13 of the diamonds
you could have even have counted
actually you know ace 2 3 4 and so on
but that would have been kind of a slow
way to do it I want to give you the
right answer though 30 down to 52
each letter of the word isosceles the
worst spelled word in the history of all
bets exams is written on a card placed
in a hat you would have a nice diagram
for you then they choose one at random
what's the probably of choosing unique
how many E's of it two one two and there
are nine letters in total so that's
where your to Avenue comes from John has
a bag of 15 marbles the probability of
selecting a yellow one is 2/3 okay so
that means two-thirds of the marbles are
yellow so that's why he goes two-thirds
of the marbles of which they're 15 and
that's where he gets 10 you could go in
reverse and check that if we ask for the
probability of a yellow marbles you'd
say well it'd be ten yellow bubbles out
of 15 total and that's two-thirds just
like they told you so you can check your
answer